it's the kind of pick-me-up that'll stay
with you all day a cup of coffee truly
changing lives there's a new spot in the
arts district that offers kindness
coffee inclusion
this sign is up and the beans are
Brewing but when you walk into this
coffee house hi welcome to decal may I
help you you'll be leaving with much
more than just a cup of joe can I get a
maple spice latte dig it coffee and
braces and celebrates uniqueness
inspiring people of all abilities it's
not just about disabilities but it's
about everyone working together and kind
of providing a place where everyone
feels like they belong Taylor Chaney is
the owner and founder my little sister
Lindsay is kind of my inspiration for
everything she was born with Down
Syndrome I really wanted to provide her
and her peers opportunities that they
don't necessarily have it's about
teamwork creating a space where everyone
is welcome where the future is bright
the thing that I think about you know
what can she do when she gets old enough
you know where will she fit in and you
know and this place is it I can't even
tell you what that means because I wish
that my mom or all parents were to have
something like this that they could see
a future for their children to know that
there's not you know a limit on
possibility that there's so much
potential and here you don't have to
look too hard to see it would you like
it for you to go there's a whole
community of people that are just
thriving they may have an intellectual
disability it may take them a little
longer but they're thriving they're
living and yes dig it offers the basics
but here it's really about the
extraordinary our bathwater is famous
comes with a fun surprise little rubber
ducky on top what you see on the outside
doesn't even come close to the goodness
within there's nothing down about it and
we are part of the lucky few
dig it is open seven days a week eight
to four Taylor said one of the things
that she is most proud of is that they
offer a competitive wage in fact she
says there is no shortage of folks who'd
like to work there so you've got to
check it out it's on Casino Center and
Colorado in the arts district and you
will just great coffee but you will
leave with a smile that's the best it's
just wonderful it's the best I love that
story